see through this they're not fools okay
good to see both of you thank you very
much indeed for taking the time to join
us on the program this morning our
political editor beth rippy is also um
here with us this morning as we count
down to prime minister's questions the
last but one penultimate as they might
say better yeah that's right the second
from last uh prime minister's questions
for boris johnson and this will be his
first public appearance really uh since
he made that speech at downing street on
thursday i did interview him on monday
on a visit to the crick institute a
science institute in the center of
london and he batted off any reflection
at all about the past events he just
said that his job was to fulfill the
mandate but i'm sure that what mps will
want to see today
is how does he handle pmqs
we also think and this is coming from
labour sources that the prime minister
might
announce
his own confidence motion in the
government at pmq's today it's not clear
when that debatable vote would take
place but you remember kay yesterday a
request for a confidence motion in the
government and pm was turned down by
number 10 so will boris johnson try and
uh steal um
steal the initiative and do that at the
top of pmq's as for kirstama i think
he's now looking
to the next lead of the next regime and
i imagine what he will want to do at
this pmqs is to try and uh
draw some lines between the various
promises uh that would be successors
make and criticize that and try and draw
the prime minister perhaps into
criticizing some of those runners and
riders and we do know
um that particularly with a couple of
them uh boris johnson's allies certainty
very angry uh at some of the handling of
uh rivals in recent days over what
happened to boris johnson namely rishi
sunak clearly in the line of fire uh for
the likes of jacob reese morgan and
nadine doris and james cleverley three
uh johnson loyalists all highly critical
of the prime minister uh sorry of rishi
sanak in recent days
um and beth this is the fun bit where we
play where's wally isn't it and we try
and figure out who is on the front
benches um who'll be asking the
questions
who i i think i've seen nadine doris um
but i'm guessing that she's gonna be
quite bullish she's very protective of
the price very protective very upset
last night um
she put a tweet out last night um around
rumors that jeremy uh hunt that the
rishi sonic team was trying to put lend
votes to jeremy hunt's team to get him
through into that first ballot which
we're going to have later today she was
very critical of that that was given
shark shrift by uh rishi sanak's team
but the point being
that this is now a very very bitter
contest it's a very short contest
and the three running candidates really
which are uh penny mordant rishi sunak
and liz trust there is a real battle now
between those three camps as to who can
get through to the final two they're the
sort of three favorites at the moment
okay thanks beth it's it's midday uh you
just watch out for the speaker in the
center of your screen when he stands up
and calls for the prime minister the
ultimate occasion that will be boris
johnson and then we will have 35 40
minutes of prime minister's questions
boris johnson just having sat down there
as well and i can see i think i'm
writing saying beth in blackfoot there
for the snp leader in westminster of
course kirstama will be there as well
and uh the loyal lieutenant for boris
johnson in the form of the deputy prime
minister many thought that he would be
standing in but that's not going to
happen
no
also it must have been quite hard for
boris johnson that dominic raab came out
in support of rishi sanak this morning
as well steve barkley who the prime
minister made his chief of staff and
then health secretary also back in rishi
sanak so the boris cabinet is certainly
split in between trust and sunoc right
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker
from tomorrow
[Applause]
i will not tolerate such behavior
if you want to go out go out now but if
you stand again i'll load you up make
your mind up and then shut up and get
out
i warned y'all no member
that they think straw testing currently
going to shut up a minute
[Music]
just somebody walk around
do what once
[Music]
that if they persist in refusing to
comply with my order to withdraw i shall
be content compelled to name both of
them which may lead to them being
suspended from the house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am now naming you and kenny mccaskill
to leave this chamber shall i just deal
with them deal with them
deal with them just sit down
no sergeants at arms escort them out
saint the right sergeant
no then let's just see if we can
mr costa you don't want to go and escort
them to the tea room do you
no i suggest not i think you're good and
better behaved than that right we'll try
again after that
prime minister will no go to robin
miller
[Music]
mr speaker from tomorrow the first
installment of the cost of living
payment will start landing in the bank
accounts of eight million households
across the country this is a much needed
326 pound cash boost
for families and forms part of the 1 200
in direct support that we're giving to
the most vulnerable households this year
mr speaker i'm sure the whole house was
appalled and saddened as i was to hear
about the despicable attack on shinzo
abe
our thoughts with his family and loved
ones and the people of japan at this
dark and sad time
mr speaker this week we remember the
genocide in srebrenica and the victims
of those appalling events
we must learn the lessons of history and
do all in our power to prevent such a
thing happening again
we will continue to combat war crime
deniers both in bosnia herzegovina and
elsewhere mr speaker this morning i had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others in addition to my duties in this
house i shall have further such meetings
later today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for his personal interest
in abba conway whether he's been eating
ice cream on the pier in landino
sampling welsh pandarian whiskey or
standing on the granite quarry in
penguin mao
[Music]
seen why
they love this constituency he's also
heard from them their gratitude for the
vaccine and furlough programs
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're my right honourable friend let
me know where it is now support our plan
to level up a conway and our bid for
almost 20 million pounds of funding to
invest in community and cultural
programs and give us the opportunity to
match our potential
i thank my honorable friend and he's a
great champion for uh for abercrombie
and i i much enjoyed the the pandarian
whiskey uh that we uh sampled uh
together mr speaker i ignored the
revolver as some of you may have noticed
we are we are committed to uniting and
leveling up the uk and uh as for the
second round of the leveling up fund
announcements it will be uh coming mr
speaker this autumn
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kirstar
mr speaker may i join the prime minister
on his comments about the former prime
minister of japan a deeply shocking
moment and of course his comments about
genocide
mr speaker may i welcome the new cabinet
to their places
we have a new chancellor accepted a job
from the prime minister on wednesday
afternoon and then told him to quit on
thursday morning
and you
and your northern ireland secretary who
once asked if you need a passport to get
to derry
and the new education secretary whose
junior ministers have literally been
giving the middle finger to the public
it is truly the country's loss that they
will only be in post for a few weeks
now
the prime minister must be feeling
demore puppy since he was pushed out of
office finally he can throw off the
shackles say what he really thinks and
forget about following the rules
[Laughter]
so
does he agree
does he agree it's time to scrap the
absurd non-dom status that allows the
super-rich to dodge tax in this country
well i could tell i thank you very much
and uh it's perfectly true that uh i i'm
grateful for uh the ability to speak my
much i never really uh lost mr speaker
but what i'm focusing on is continuing
the government of the of the country and
as as i've just told you mr speaker
tomorrow from tomorrow 326 pounds is
arriving never mind non-doms mr speaker
doms doms or non-doms i don't mind uh
with 326 pounds is arriving is arriving
in the bank accounts of 8 million of
vulnerable people
and
how can we do that because we took the
decisions
to get the strong economy that we
currently have that i'm afraid uh were
resisted uh by sorry growth growth in
may at naught point five percent mr
speaker uh which which they weren't
expecting we have see as i've told you
before it's bigger 620 000 more people
in paid in payroll employment than
before the pandemic began
and one of the constellations of leaving
office at this particular time mr
speaker is that vacancies are at an
all-time high
yes
cut him some slack faced with an
uncertain future a mortgage-sized
decorators bill
they'll be soon for somebody else's flat
i'm not surprised he's careful not to
upset any future employers
so here's an even simpler one
does he agree that offshore schemes can
pose a risk because some people use them
to avoid tax they owe here
minister
mr speaker i'm proud of the investment
that this country uh attracts from from
around the world and uh he's talking
about uh people from offshore people
investing in the uk uh absolutely
thrilled uh to see uh that we've had i
think 12 billion in tech alone uh coming
in the last in the last couple of uh
last couple of months i think if
possible mr speaker he's referring uh
not to me uh but
some of the eight brilliant candidates
who are currently buying uh for my job
let me just tell let me just tell him
that let me just tell him that any one
of them will wipe the floor with captain
captain cook
wipe the floor
let me just say the furniture has to be
repaired and one of the members already
at one bill i'm sure he doesn't want
another prime minister
any one of them would wipe the floor
with captain crasher rooney's snooze
fest
and and after a few weeks time
that is exactly what they will do they
will unite around the winner and do just
that
[Applause]
he's been saying all week that he wants
revenge on those that have wronged him
here's an idea prime minister
if he
if he really wants to hit them where it
hurts he should tighten the rules on tax
avoidance
but at the very least does he agree that
anyone running to be prime minister
should declare where they and their
families have been domiciled for tax
purposes and whether they've ever been a
beneficiary of an offshore tax scheme
[Applause]
[Music]
prime minister mr mr speaker to the best
of my knowledge uh everybody in this
parliament everybody in this house pays
their full whack of tax in this country
and i think that people should members
of members across the house should be uh
should be should cease this constant
vitification of each other i think
people pay their fair share of taxes uh
and and quite right uh what we're doing
and it's thanks to the tax yield that we
have had uh that we're able to support
the people of this country in the way uh
that we are uh so so we've been able to
increase a universal credit uh by a
thousand pounds uh mr speaker uh we're
putting 356 pounds into the
from tomorrow into the bank accounts of
those uh who need it most mr speaker and
thanks to the policies we have pursued
as i have just uh told you we have
unemployment at or near record lows and
that is what council has become they are
very happy to see people languish on
benefits we believe in getting people
into good jobs and
i'm looking for one mr speaker i'm not
sure he's been keeping up with what's
happening the last few days over the
weekend the candidates to replace him
have promised
330 billion pounds in giveaways
that's that's roughly double the annual
budget for the nhs
sadly they haven't found time to explain
how they're paying for it
even though one of them's the chancellor
and another one was chancellor until a
week ago
they all backed 15 tax rises
now they're acting as if they've just
arrived from the moon saying it should
never have happened
doesn't he agree that rather than
desperately rewriting history they
should at least explain exactly where
they're getting all this cash from
prime minister
actually mr speaker he's cur he's
completely right i've been listening
very i've been listening very carefully
and uh all the all the uh commitments
that i'm listening to are very very good
we will continue whoever is elected will
continue uh to put more police out on
the street exactly as we exactly as we
promised already at thirteen thousand
five hundred seventy six we're gonna go
up to twenty thousand uh whoever takes
over will build he they always complain
about this but we will build the 40 new
hospitals mr speaker
and i i asked mike
i asked my delivery unit yesterday well
they don't want it they don't like it
it's because they voted against the
funding they voted against the funding
that makes it possible mr speaker and
and they have also in just in the last
in just in the last period in which he
has been in office make extra
commitments of public spending worth 94
billion pounds which would be thousands
of pounds of extra taxation for every
family in the country mr speaker that's
the difference between them and us
[Applause]
totally totally deluded to the bitter
end
now
now to be fair
mr alden i think that's the last time i
hear from you today i think otherwise
you might be able to buy a couple of
other people cups of tea
to be fair to the new chancellor he's at
least attempted to spell it out
he's promised tens of billions in tax
cuts
and confirm
he would cut the nhs
the police
and school budgets by 20
to funding
the member for stratford and gibraltar
is complaining but he said it on tv
and yesterday
yesterday he said it's simply not right
that families are seeing their bills
skyrocket and we do nothing
was the chancellor speaking on behalf of
the government prime minister when he
promised huge spending cuts and when he
said that they're doing nothing on the
cost of living crisis
prime minister
look mr speaker this is really a pity
pitiful stuff from the party
the party that that voted against the 39
billion pounds uh which is necessary to
pay for those 50 000 uh nurses uh which
we're recruiting and we will recruit by
2024 mr speaker which is necessary to
pay for those hospitals and those
doctors and those scans and that
treatment they they don't have a leg to
to stand on mr speaker and and and i can
tell him something else the reason the
reason we've got growth now at uh 0.5 in
may is is because we took the tough
decisions to come out of uh lockdown on
july the 19th last year which he said
was reckless never forget he said it was
reckless we our economy would not be
strong enough now to make the payments
we are to our fantastic nhs and they
know
i really am going to miss this weekly
nonsense from him
let's
let's move on
let's move on from his current
chancellor to his former chancellor
last week he resigned
accusing the prime minister of not
conducting government
properly competently or seriously
he suggested the prime minister is not
prepared to work hard or take difficult
decisions
and implied that the prime minister
cannot tell the public the truth
yesterday
he claimed his big plan
is to rebuild the economy now even the
prime minister must be impressed by that
johnson brass neckery
can the prime minister think of any jobs
his former chancellor may have had that
means he bears some responsibility for
an economy that he now claims is broken
prime minister
uh mr speaker i i look i think everybody
who's played a part in uh the last three
years has done a a remarkable job in
helping this country through very
difficult times i i just want to say tim
really uh this may mr speaker the next
leader of the of my party may be elected
by acclimation so it's possible uh this
will be our last uh our last
confrontation over this just about it's
possible so i want to thank him
i want to thank him for the style in
which he's conducted himself i think
it'd be fair to say he's been
considerably less lethal than many other
members of this house
and i'll tell you why that is
i'll tell you why that is because he
hasn't come up
can i just say to this end of this front
bench
i expect better behavior and i'm
certainly going to get it prime minister
yeah
there's a reason for that mr speaker is
over over three years in spite of every
opportunity he's never really come up
with an idea a plan or a vision for this
for this country
and i can tell you that at the end of at
the end of three years mr speaker we got
brexit done which he voted against 48
times
we deliver the first vaccine in the
world and roll it out faster than any
other european country which would never
be possibly listen to him mr speaker and
we played a decisive role in helping to
protect the people of ukraine from the
brutal invasion of vladimir putin and
helped to save ukraine mr speak and i'm
proud to say that we are continuing and
every one of the eight candidates will
continue with the biggest ever program
of infrastructure skills and technology
across this country to level up in a way
in a way that will benefit the
constituents of every member of this
house mr speaker and it's perfectly true
it's perfectly true that i leave not at
a time of my choosing and it's
absolutely true but i am i am proud of
the fantastic teamwork that has been
involved in all of those projects both
nationally and and internationally mr
speaker and i'm also proud of the
leadership that i have given and i will
be leaving mr speaker
i will be leaving soon with
my head held high
[Applause]
the convicted double child rapist
and murderer of colin pitchfork was
granted parole last year by the
independent parole board
in the face of enormous opposition from
whistleblowers and my south
leicestershire constituents
only two months after he was released
he was recalled to prison for having
breached his license conditions
he has another parole board hearing
scheduled for september
prime minister you and i have
communicated about this matter on
numerous occasions
and you've ensured assured me that you
would do everything in your power
to deal with this situation
can you confirm
before you leave office
that your government will make all the
necessary submissions that it can make
lawfully
to the independent parole board
to make sure that this dangerous man is
kept behind bars
my honourable friend for his campaign
our thoughts of course with the victims
of pitchfork uh uh lydia
and dawn's friends and family and uh mr
speaker i can tell the house that uh my
right on from the deputy prime minister
will be submitting his views on the
pitchfork case uh to the parole board uh
before his hearing and there is also as
the house will know a root and branch
review of the parole system currently
underway uh which includes plans for
greater ministerial oversight for the
most serious offenders and we'll be
bringing that forward as soon as
parliamentary time allows now come to
the leader of the smp ian black
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister in the murder of shinzo abe a
dreadful event that took place last
weekend can i also thank you mr speaker
for hosting last night the charity
remembering seveniza we should all take
time this week
on the 27th anniversary of the genocide
that took place there to think of the
circumstances and the shame that we were
not able to step in and stop the murder
of so many innocent
boys and men and the rape of so many
women and that we must learn the lessons
from that and of course at this time we
think very much of those in ukraine that
are facing a war criminal and make sure
that those responsible are ultimately
held to account for crimes against
humanity
mr speaker the tory leadership contest
is quickly descending into a toxic race
to the right and it's clear that whoever
wins that race scotland loses
the former chancellor has pledged to
govern like margaret thatcher the
current chancellor is threatening 20
cuts to the nhs and public services and
they're all trying to outdo each other
on an extreme brexit costing the economy
billions
it's the real reason that the prime
minister won't endorse any of these
awful candidates because whoever becomes
the next tory leader will make genjis
khan look
[Applause]
[Music]
i feel a real twinge mr speaker that
this is uh probably all virtually the
last time i have the opportunity to uh
to answer a question to the
perhaps because he's going over because
i'm going i don't know uh but
mr speaker i
all i would say to him is that uh i
think that the uh next uh leader of of
my party uh will i want to make sure
that we do everything we can to work
with the uh the scottish government in
the way that i've been able to do i'm
proud to have done over the last uh a
few years to protect and secure our
union and uh my strong view mr speaker
having listened to him very carefully uh
for years and years now is that we are
much much better together
in blackfoot i can see with all
sincerity i hope whoever is the next
story leader will be as popular in
scotland as he has been
[Applause]
for people in scotland
westminster has never looked so out of
touch we've got right-wing tory
contenders prioritizing tax cuts for the
rich and a zombie uk government failing
to tackle the cost of living prices well
satori's are busy tearing lump outs of
each other money-saving expert martin
lewis has warned the energy price cap
could soon rise by a sickening 65 in
october to 3 244 pounds a year after a
decade of tory cuts and brexit price
rises it will mean many families simply
can't afford to put food on the table
and heat their homes scotland literally
can't afford the cost of living with
westminster
does the prime minister not get that
people in scotland don't just want rid
of him they want rid of the whole rotten
westminster system
[Applause]
mr speaker i actually i think that's not
what is actually happening in this
country is that we're using the the
fiscal firepower that we built up to to
cut taxes uh for for working people cut
taxes for those on low incomes and uh
you saw that last week uh in the 300
average of 330 pound uh tax cut of on
national insurance we're increasing
support for those uh vulnerable
households from tomorrow another 326
pounds going in uh mr speaker it's
thanks to our union uh that we were able
to uh we were able to deliver uh the
furlough scheme which helped uh the
entire country and uh to make the the
massive transfers uh that boost the
whole of the uk economy and i think uh
that the people who's the last thing
that people in scotland uh need now uh
and all the nasty
the last thing they need is more
constitutional wrangling uh when uh we
need to fix the economy mary robinson
thank you mr speaker after securing
almost 14 million pounds in my towns
from the bid for chill i was delighted
last week to get the green lights for
our new chino rail station
and four million pounds for our
state-of-the-art eco business park
i've had tremendous support from the
cheadle towns board and local community
who understand how important it is to
have connected towns and villages
bringing investment and high-tech jobs
to our area
i'm ambitious for cheadle and i want to
secure the redoubling of the midcheshire
line and the extension of metrolink
through my constituency will my right
honourable friend join me in thanking
the towns ford and station working group
for their support and agree with me that
improving connectivity is key to
economic growth and the future of our
leveling of yeah
[Applause]
mr speaker thanks to the massive
exertions of this government in leveling
up uh with the 650 billion pound
investment in uh in infrastructure uh
that were uh up we haven't got a new
railway station in chido uh for instance
uh mr speaker and uh i know that the
bids that uh my honorable friend has
just mentioned are now being actively uh
studied by the department for transport
and uh she should feed in and more to
them
stephen farrell thank you in a recent
opinion poll conducted by lucid talk for
queens university only five percent of
the people of northern ireland expressed
any trust whatsoever in this government
so as the prime minister prepares to
leave office shortly
will he apologize for his legacy in
northern ireland
which power sharing has collapsed the
good fight agreement has been undermined
an unwanted protocol bill has been
imposed by the people and businesses of
north darlings and anchorage relations
are in their worst yet for 40
prime
years
well mr no mr speaker because actually
what we've got and i know that every
single one of the uh candidates will
want to uh deliver this is a bill to to
fix the problem of the of the protocol
and i accept that there is a uh there is
a problem and i hope that the whole
house will i will support it
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah thank you uh mr speaker
and as this is probably the last time
i'll get to address the prime minister
this dispatchbox can i say on behalf of
the people of red crew in cleveland how
grateful we are for the support that
he's given us
delivering on the will of 17.4 million
people in taking us out of the eu can i
ask the prime minister is he as
optimistic as i am about our future as a
free and independent nation
[Applause]
jacob i mean
my my horrible friend if anything i
think i'm even i'm even more optimistic
and my only anxiety we all know that
people think that this will be there are
people around the world who hope that
this will be the end of the end of
brexit and uh i can see them all look at
them
did you notice
[Applause]
them they're wrong mr speaker and we're
going to show that they're wrong
we now come to martin day
mr speaker if the uk truly is a
voluntary union of equal nations there
must be a democratic way for any of
those member nations to withdraw from it
does the pm think the role of the uk
government is to decide whether to
respect the mandate given by the people
of scotland
to their government and endorsed by
their parliament
prime minister uh mr speaker as i
continually advise the the members of
the scottish national party or
nationalist party i should say uh they
should look at what is happening in
educational standards in scotland which
they are responsible which they are
responsible for
instead instead of endlessly asking
for a repeat of a of a constitutional
event that we had in 2014 we had a vote
mr speaker they lost
catherine fletcher
mr speaker the prime minister knows how
proud we are of our industrial heritage
in the north of england and what it
means for our future so last friday it
was a joy to be on the banks of the
river with the friends of the old tram
bridge a group that are asking for this
historic piece of industrial
architecture that crosses the ribble to
be reopened vote for the utility and
because we're bloody proud of it so does
the prime minister
share my hope that preston city council
will include the plans to get the bridge
reopened as part of their leveling up
fund bid
well uh mr speaker i think it's probably
possibly fair to say that i'm i'm
responsible for building more more
more river crossings than anybody else
in this uh in this house uh uh including
and bridges uh including suggests lane
suggests lame crossing mr speaker which
i delivered uh for my honourable friend
uh i i think at this stage in my
political career i could not in all in
all honesty promise that i can deliver
this bridge uh
i think i think that she that she has
eight people to whom uh she could direct
that request uh right now and i said
she's in a strong bargaining position
[Laughter]
child poverty has increased in every
part of wales in the last seven years
under tory cuts to public services and
malign welfare policies
in the communities
i represent
37 percent of children are now growing
up in poverty he has one last chance to
make a real difference to these
children's lives before he leaves office
will he scrap
the two-trial limit and reinstate the
20-pound uplift for all families
entitled to welfare yeah
mr speaker of course the labor
government in wales is responsible for
schools but what we have been doing uh
what we have been doing is not only uh
increasing the uh the living wage by a
thousand pounds uh providing the the
financial support the 37 billion pounds
worth of financial support uh that i
have i've mentioned but uh helping
councils uh mr speaker with a one and a
half billion uh household uh support
fund uh to get the families such as
those uh she mentions uh through uh the
tough times and we will come out very
strongly at the other side
we now come to a close questions to mike
penning number eight mr speaker minister
i thank my honorable friend i'm
delighted that there will be a new
hospital scheme in this area i'm told
that the local hospital trusts have
considered a full range of options and
that they consider that new hospital
builds at watford general alongside
further investment at hemel hempstead
and synorbons hospitals represent the
best option for health services in the
area
so my pending can i thank the prime
minister for delivering brexit and the
fantastic vaccine rollout
program but i was proud to be involved
with and save so many lives in my
constituents and around the country
sadly the trust i've not considered all
options and then my constituents will be
astonished as to what they have said by
saying that they now want 1.2 billion
pounds for the refurbished tower block
situation in watford so can the prime
minister do me a great favor before he
leaves can he put a little note in the
draw of number 10 so when the new
incumbent comes in to say penning needs
a new hospital on a greenfield site
uh well mr speaker i can tell him that
i'll you can get i will assure he gets
uh a meeting with the relevant minister
to discuss his proposals
john trickett
thank you sir um we now know that every
ambulance service in the whole country
is in a critical state
but last week well before the current
national heatwave emergency
my constituent mrs meacham
died
following waiting for hours
for an ambulance and in this in an
excruciating and prolonged delay
her daughter tells me that the family
tragedy wasn't called caused by the
staff but by cutbacks by this government
but in any event
without immediate and drastic action we
cannot be sure that there will be more
many more mrs meacham's
just a pm except
we now are living through an emergency
health crisis
and given a disastrous state he's
leaving the nhs in why is he still in
downing street
mr speaker the
nhs now has a record
he talks about staffing levels the nhs
now has a record number of uh of people
working in it ten thousand nine hundred
more nurses this year than there were
last year six thousand more more doctors
and on ambulances which and he's right
it's absolutely critical uh the the
crucial thing is to is to help the
hospital staff to move patients through
the system and too often i'm afraid it
is impossible because a proportion of
the patients sadly are in a delayed uh
discharge and that is making life very
very difficult for the ambulances as
they come up at the hospital but that is
why it is so crucial that this
government in addition to everything
else we've done mr speaker is fixing
social care and helping and helping
patients out of hospital and that's why
we put in the 39 billion pounds mr
speaker which unfortunately uh his party
voted against raritan
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for all he's done to help
level up stoke-on-trent
the number of the number of workless
households in our city has halved under
the last
decade of conservatives in government so
would my right friend agree that the
best way to level up stoke on trent is
to get more people in well-skilled
better paid employment opportunities
[Applause]
i think he's absolutely right and the
right honourable gentleman knows a lot
more about stoke newington than he knows
about stoke and that's
that is absolutely true uh mr speaker
and i and i'm proud that we're getting
people young people into work
up and down the country i was at an
event last night uh to celebrate the 163
000 uh kickstarters uh who we've helped
uh into work and that is our ambition to
help people into good jobs and we are
succeeding i'm proud to say i leave
office mr speaker with unemployment at
roughly 3.8 when they laughed at last
left office it was at eight percent
that's the difference between them and
us
malcolm mcdonald thank you thank you mr
speaker last night's panorama with the
joint investigation with the times
newspaper has exposed yet again more
evidence
of unlawful killings by special forces
this time in afghanistan
when this came up before the government
and in particular the mod was determined
to sweep this
under the carpet
but those who serve in uniform
and the public they protect deserve
better than this these aren't vexatious
claims from
campaigning lawyers they come from
within the armed forces themselves and
indeed from our allies in australia so
will the prime minister commit to an
australia-style independent inquiry as
backed by general lord richards but more
broadly hasn't the case been made again
for democratic oversight of special
forces
uh mr speaker it's a long-standing uh
practice i think accepted on both sides
of this house that we do not comment on
on special forces and that does not mean
uh that we in any way accept the factual
accuracy of the claims to which he is
eluded on the other hand mr speaker nor
does it mean that anybody who serves in
her majesty's armed forces is above the
law
[Music]
just one of the members that there is a
subjunacy on this i allowed that
question because it was very general and
that's the only way i would ever allow
it to be discussed at the moment andrew
luer
thank you mr speaker
in the last few years campaigning and
persistence have led to the construction
of a new children's a e and just this
year a new main a e for northampton
general hospital in my constituency
building on this success what the town
now needs is an urgent treatment center
does the prime minister agree that this
would be a hugely welcome step in
providing top quality health care in
northampton
prime minister this is because as i
mentioned i think earlier on uh we're
engaged in a massive program of uh
improvements and building and rebuilding
in our in our nhs estate uh
i think that uh with great respect to my
uh honorable friend uh this is a
decision that he's going to have to
continue to to lobby for i think the
local nhs bodies uh will uh will have to
have to make up their their minds on
that one but i'm sure he will continue
to make lively representations patricia
gibbs thank you mr speaker last week the
prime minister was forced to announce
his intention to resign after ministers
who supported him only days earlier
changed their minds of course people are
allowed to change their minds and this
should be recognized
why does the prime minister and his mps
believe this principle applies
everywhere except in scotland
where the people delivered a clear
mandate to the scottish parliament to
hold an independence referendum
prime minister
well this is because i understand that
the people of the snp are currently
deciding what to do with my honorable
friend
[Applause]
heaven heaven forfeit that they should
change their minds mr speaker
thank you mr speaker mr speaker 40 years
ago
10 young people from rugby's west indian
community traveled to a house in new
cross road london for a birthday
celebration for raw former rugby
resident yvonne ruddick
tragically there was a fire at the house
where the party was held and two of that
group never returned home others were
traumatized the fire cost 13 people
their lives and has been the subject of
two inquests both of which were
inconclusive
those who survived and the families of
the bereaved are calling for a further
investigation and if the prime minister
would agree that the appointment of the
new metropolitan police commissioner
provides an opportunity to re-examine
the events of that time
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend and i know from my own experience
of running uh the city of the anguish
that that particular uh tragedy uh
caused and i know the deep feeling uh
that surrounds it mr speaker i thank him
uh for for raising it and i can i can
tell him uh of course that uh whatever
my own views this is a matter for the
independent uh metropolitan uh police
service and i'm sure the new uh
commissioner will be considering uh what
he has just said
i love brown
thank you mr speaker while he was editor
of the spectator it published a form of
exterminating the scotch a verminous
race he previously stated that a pound
spent in croydon is of more value to the
country in the pound
strathclyde they called for an ending of
the environment former he stated an mp
from a scottish constituency shouldn't
be a prime minister
so governor's andy scott's views is
abject failure as a prime minister why
did he think he's a right to try and
block a democratic vote for scotland to
choose his future away from his corrupt
waste minister
can i just say to
to the the honorable gentleman that
after three years of listening to this
uh delirium of monotony uh from the
scottish nationalists i really think
they need to change the record uh what
the people of this country want is a
focus on the cost of living a focus on
the economy and making sure on schools
mr speaker on standards in schools those
are things that he should fix mr speaker
and to say nothing of the tragedy of
drug deaths in scotland and mr speaker
which they still have which they still
which they still haven't done anything
to address mr speaker and everything i
have seen has taught me uh that we are
far far better whether it's on ukraine
or covid mr speaker or on furlough
there's absolutely no doubt mr speaker
that we are better off working together
thank you mr speaker
kensington is at the heart of the
ukrainian community and on their behalf
i would like to first send their huge
thanks for your support to ukraine
yesterday was the first year anniversary
of the devastating flooding that
affected my constituency with more than
1 000 homes affected people in basement
flats losing all of their belongings and
many people still in temporary
accommodation
would my right honorable friend back my
fight to ensure that we get serious
investment in infrastructure in west
london from thames water
prime minister i i thank her very much
and i i i i know that i know the problem
that she speaks of uh very well there's
no single solution to tackling uh
surface water uh flooding uh but uh
she's absolutely right in wanting to put
more pressure on thames water to try to
come up uh with sustainable solutions
but they've got to be done working with
uh with partners with councils and of
course with developers as well
final question sam terry thank you mr
speaker
a few short weeks ago
zara lena was walking home through
illford she was dragged off the street
and brutally murdered
zara's family made a touching tribute to
her life
she was authentic refused to try and
impress anyone but she impressed us she
was the rock of our family
last week on the 8th of july another
woman was stabbed in saint john's road
just yards from my family's church that
i attended for 15 years so i know like
the back of my hand
women in ilford should not have to
police themselves or impose curfews on
their behavior when they want to just go
about their daily business
so mr speaker i want to know whether the
prime minister will commit to greater
allocation of funding in terms of
policing that's targeted on specialist
knife crime into ilford and across all
of that part of north east london and in
addition mr speaker what measures will
this government actually take that will
make a difference to the lives of women
all they toughen sentences for rape
stalking domestic violence and put in
place proper police support to end mr
speaker the epidemic of violence in this
country against women and girls
just before the prime minister answered
sorry just to say it's very important
i've allowed it to raise be careful
going into detail on the first name
because it is subject but in general
terms i'm sure that we can answer it
prime
minister i i thank you mr speaker for
your guidance but i think i think we can
say safely how much we sympathize with
the uh the victim and and her her family
and on on life crime it is a it is a
scourge uh mr speaker and i believe
there are many uh
different solutions but one of them is
unquestionably allowing the police to do
uh more stop and search and uh making
sure you have more police out on the
street and that's why we've made the
massive investments that we have and i
hope that those investments will be
continued this week i'm sure that they
and they will be and on on on rape and
serious sexual offenses offenses
particularly against uh against women
this is this is incredibly important to
the whole house and it's something that
we have worked on very hard over the
last uh three years and uh what we have
what we have done uh mr speaker is not
only uh introduced more uh street lights
and done everything we can to give our
women invested more into independent uh
sexual violence advisers and domestic
violence advisors and all the people you
need to give victims the confidence they
need to get cases to trial which is such
a such a problem uh mr speaker but what
we've also done
what we've also done in addition to
putting more police out on the streets
and and specialist units to tackle is we
have what we've also done is introduced
a tougher sentences for rape and serious
uh sexual uh sexual advancement speaker
and i have to say i was amazed and it's
still the case that his party voted
against those tougher sentences that was
a great mistake and i think they should
take it back
at the start of prime minister's
questions the honourable member
free slovian coccoli and code and bait
persistently denied the authority of the
chair
in their absence
i wish to proceed to name them and call
on the leader to move the relevant
names so i named kenny muscle
neil hamby and i'm sure now the lead
will pick it up
uh mr speaker i beg to move that kenny
mccaskill and neil mv be suspended from
the service of this house
[Music]
the question is that kenny mccaskill and
neil hanbib is suspended from this house
as many of their opinions say aye
the country now
we now move to the urgent question a
call west reading
okay just a moment or two we'll hear
from wes streeting who of course is the
shadow health secretary he's got an
urgent question about the ambulance
service here both in wales and england
they are presently operating on high
alert levels for two reasons temperature
that could go into the 40s is what we
are being told right into next tuesday
what sort of problems will that cause
for the ambulance service and in
addition to that kovid shortages as well
right in which case i will take that one
point forward
so my penny as a former minister i'm
very aware of the information that's
given to ministers and prime ministers
when they're going to answer a question
especially when the question has been
pre-informed
the the information the speaker was
given was that they were that my trust
my hospital tricep looks at all options
looks at all options put a decision on
the new hospital in my in my part of the
world that is not correct mr speaker and
i wish to put on the record that the
prime minister has been misled by my
trust and it's not the prime minister's
fault that he had that information
i'm not going to carry on the debate of
the question but i would say you
certainly go on the record i'm sure the
trust will be reading as you sat down
right let's try again with urgent
question where's
thank you mr speaker to ask the new
secretary of state if he will make a
statement on ambulance services and the
declaration of a national heatwave
emergency
minister um
thank you uh mr speaker our ambulance
service performs heroics every single
day and i want to put on record my
thanks to every single one of them for
all education and hard work and we do
have a duty to support this vital
service and give them the resources and
support they need the latest figures
from the nhs in england show that
ambulance service response time
performance has improved month on month
and also the ambulance hours lost
is also improving month a month a month
or month as well however we do fully
acknowledge that there are rising
pressures facing the service and there
are three significant factors
influencing this first bed occupancy
which is currently around 93 which is
something we'd normally see
around winter times is influencing this
we know that there's high rates of
covert admissions in hospital whether
that's people with covid or because of
covid and that puts pressure on a e's to
be able to admit patients we're roughly
running on void beds of around 1 200 and
part of this is because there's a 16
increase in length of stays we also have
the pressures of delayed discharges but
they remain flat but a significant
influence but also we have record
numbers of uh calls the ambulance
service at 100 000 more calls compared
to may last year so there is significant
pressure on the system as well as that
we also have to be mindful of the
weather in the coming days we do have a
heatwave plan for england which was
published earlier this year i'm sure the
honourable gentleman has read it and we
also have the hot weather plans the nhs
trust have also put in place
in addition to that we're providing
sector-specific guidance setting up the
best way to protect people who may be at
risk but we're also supporting the
service more widely to make sure it's
got the resilience it needs we've
allocated 150 million pounds of extra
funding for this year for the ambulance
service and we're boosting the workforce
too
national 999 core handler numbers have
risen to nearly 2 300 at the start of
june which is a considerable increase on
the previous september and we're on
track
to train 3 000 paramedic graduates
nationally per year every year until
2024. and on top of this we've invested
50 million pounds uh in nhs 111 to help
give extra capacity to the service i
will be meeting uh all 11 ambulance
trusts over the coming days to make sure
that they have the capacity and
resilience they need not just to deal
with the pressures now not just to deal
with the pressures with the war weather
but to prepare for the winter pressures
that we know will be inevitable and
forthcoming this is an important issue
which i take extremely seriously and i
will keep the house updated as the
situation develops
we now come to shuttle secretary of
state again
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
granting this urgent question but what a
disgrace that the secretary of state
isn't here our nhs is going through the
biggest crisis in its history every
ambulance service is on the highest
level of alert patients are forced to
wait hours in pain and discomfort and he
is yet to say a word about any of it the
home secretary wasn't at the home
affairs select committee this morning
he's not here this afternoon this isn't
even a government in office let alone in
power one person who is still in office
however is the minister her boss
resigned saying he couldn't put loyalty
above integrity any longer well the
minister obviously made a different
choice so can she say whether any
further meetings of cobra are scheduled
beyond the meeting held on monday and as
we saw during the pandemic public health
emergencies require clear communication
from government can she tell the house
what the consequence of a national
heatwave emergency would be for schools
for public transport services and other
public services and what guidance will
be provided to the general public what
assessment has she made of the
suitability of care homes to protect
residents from the extreme heat and what
contingencies are in place should
further measures be necessary
every ambulance service is now on the
highest level of alert so what is the
secretary of state doing about it the
minister talks about targeted help for
ambulance services she's going to be
hitting the phones this week presumably
the secretary of state's too busy but
this as i think she acknowledged is a
crisis across the health service last
month a crew in the west midlands
weighted can we um with apologies to
west trading the shadow health secretary
must leave it there because we do want
to get the thoughts uh from our
political editor of course uh beth rigby
and what we've heard from the prime
minister on this is penultimate prime
minister's questions beth thoughts
well there's a couple of things that
stood out for me there okay the first
was that the self belief and confidence
at least publicly of boris johnson on
full
display there
with his backbenchers uh sitting behind
them a number of who had dragged him out
of number 10 last week you remember he
said the herd moves well the herd moved
on him and they stampeded him
he stood there with them behind him and
he said
it is true that i am leaving at the time
of my not at the time of my choosing but
i'm proud of the leadership i've given i
will be leaving with my head held high
boris johnson to the end there uh
putting on a brave front
uh the other thing was the acclimation
yeah should we have a listen yeah let's
have a listen to what he actually said
and then we'll try and unpack that here
we go mr speaker the next leader of the
of my party may be elected by
acclamation so it's possible uh this
will be our last uh our last
confrontation over this just about it's
possible so i want to thank him
i want to thank him for the style in
which he's conducted himself i think
it'd be fair to say he's been
considerably less lethal than many other
members of this house
and i'll tell you why that is
over three years in spite of every
opportunity he's never really come up
with an idea a plan or a vision for this
for this country
and i can tell you that at the end of at
the end of three years mr speaker we got
brexit done which he voted against 48
times we deliver the first vaccine in
the world and roll it out past any other
european country which would never be
possibly listen to him mr speaker and we
played a decisive role in helping to
protect the people of ukraine from the
brutal invasion of vladimir putin and
help to save ukraine mr speak and i'm
proud to say that we are continuing and
every one of the eight candidates will
continue with the biggest ever program
of infrastructure skills and technology
across this country to level up in a way
in a way that will benefit the
constituents of every member of this
house mr speaker and it's perfectly true
it's perfectly true that i leave not at
a time of my choosing and it's
absolutely true but i am i am proud of
the fantastic teamwork that has been
involved in all of those projects both
nationally and and internationally mr
speaker and i'm also proud of the
leadership that i have given and i will
be leaving mr speaker
i will be leaving soon
with
my head held high
[Music]
leaving he will be um beth now what did
he mean by acclimation that was quite an
arresting moment at pmq's because what
can happen is uh when you whittle down
the candidates you get to the final two
if one person pulls out or the party
overwhelmingly go to one then
effectively that person is anointed
acclimation this is what happened with
theresa may you'll remember when andrea
ledson dropped out of the race and they
never had to go around the country now
what was arrested about that was number
one that is clearly not what sir graham
brady has said that he wants the chair
of the 22 committee who's publicly said
that he has sought assurances from
candidates that the members will have a
say over the summer when the final two
uh go uh toe to toe and try and convince
those 100 000 or so party members to
vote for them so the prime minister
saying that is actually odd that's not
as we understand what the um process uh
will be
and i wondered whether he was being a
bit frisky as well in that there was liz
truss sitting next to him he hasn't
publicly said uh that he's backing
anyone in fact he said when i asked him
did he feel betrayed and he said i'm not
getting into what how i feel or who i
might be supporting because i don't want
to
affect the race but the symbolism of liz
trust sitting there after all of his key
allies in cabinet or two of them at
least publicly backed her does he want
uh
liz trust to be anointed i mean i just
quickly spoke to someone from the 22
they said that they hope that doesn't
happen it's impossible to stay for sure
but unlikely at this stage okay well the
voting opens in around about half an
hour's time i think i'm writing saying
beth two hours of voting by five o'clock
we'll know how at least one of them has
been taken out of the race and the smart
money is on probably more than one beth
will have the latest at five
[Music]
you